Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and and here’s
my Game of Thrones Season 4 Preview for Tywin
Lannister.
The true king of Westeros and the greatest
joy vampire you’ve ever met.
Just try to be happy around him.
I dare you.
So first I’ll talk about how tywin’s character
develops in season 4 and then I’ll list
my all time top 5 Worst Twyin Lannister Moments.
If you’ve never seen any of my season 4
previews or your finding me for the first
time.
Spoilers for everything in books 1 through
3 and partial spoilers for book 4 and dance
with dragons.
Tywin Lannister really only cares about House
Lannister and as a family man he really only
cares about how the rest of the Lannisters
reflect of him.
That’s why you always see him making Tyrion,
Jaime and Cersei do strange things.
It’s hard to say whether he believes that
Joffrey is really Jaime’s son, but during
season 3 he orders Cersei to marry Loras just
so that the rumors will stop.
He never acknowledges that they’re true.
He also never acknowledges that Loras is really
gay.
So he doesn’t really care about his children.
He just cares about what they can do to help
or hurt the Lannister name.
That’s why no matter how smart Tyrion is,
he’ll always hate him, because the rest
of westeros just thinks of him as the imp.
But he’s a lannister imp goddamit.
So really all Tywin is waiting for is an excuse
to kill Tyrion that won’t reflect badly
on House Lannister.
And Season 4 gives him that chance.
Tyrion get’s blamed for the *super spoilery*
event in King’s Landing and while we don’t
have any Tywin POV chapters, it’s implied
that Tywin acts like Tyrion is guilty.
Tyrion is put on trial and since it’s a
solution to Tywin’s “Tyrion” problem
I think he doesn’t care whether Tyrion is
actually guilty.
If you saw the scene with Tyrion and Tywin
at the end of season 3.
That wasn’t in the books, the actors improvised
it just because Peter Dinklage and Charles
Dance are so awesome.
It let’s you know that Tyrion is hanging
by a thread.
Tywin is just looking for the right excuse
to get rid of him.
And Season 4 is where he gets that chance.
But if you thought that bad guys always win
in Game of Thrones, you are wrong.
Bullies never win in the end.
We can’t predict what specifically they’ll
change from the books to the show, but I expect
the untimely demise of westeros’ greatest
bully to go down just the way it does in the
books.
With some improvised dialogue from Peter Dinklage
and Charles Dance of course.
But here’s my list of Top 5 Worst Tywin
Lannister Moments So Far:
Number 5 - Killing the Last of The Targaryen’s
or so he thought.
Tywin ordered the murder of prince rhaeger
and elia of dorne and their children.
I don’t know if the success or failure of
this will make it to the show.
So I won’t include any spoilers for the
mummer’s dragon.
But the red viper is Elia’s sister and he’ll
be trying to find out who killed Elia during
season 4.
Number 4 - Hiring the Bloody Mummers to Burn
the Riverlands during the war of the five
kings.
On the show these characters are replaced
by Locke and his group of men.
He was the one that cut Jaime’s hand off.
So you can think of that as a small form of
Karmic retribution for tywin.
Number 3 - The Rains of Castamere.
So this refers to an event and a song based
on the event.
The song was turned into the Lannister theme
on the show.
So anytime there’s a lannister scene, the
tune plays softly in the background.
The event it refers to is when House Reyne
and House Tarbeck rebelled against their liege
lord Tywin’s father.
In response Tywin killed every member of their
families and burned their castles.
It was so terrible that the people of westeros
turned it into a song, that now plays every
time a lannister appears on screen in the
show.
Number 2 - The untimely demise of Tyrion’s
first wife Tysha.
So Tyrion as you can imagine had some self
esteem issues growing up.
More than most teenagers.
So when he finally fell in love with a peasant
girl named Tysha they got married.
When Tywin found out that a lannister had
married a commoner he brutalized Tysha and
lied to Tyrion he had secretly paid her to
love him.
Tyrion never found out what happened to her,
but he swore revenge.
And my number 1 worst Tywin lannister moment
- The red wedding.
Tywin was responsible for convincing Walder
Frey to perpetrate the Red Wedding in exchange
for favorable treatment.
House Frey was actually an enemy of the Lannisters
during the war of the five kings, but Tywin
promised to forgive that in exchange for the
heads of all the starks and the slaughter
of their army.
It was basically like a sequel to The Rains
of Castamere.
Which was the name of the red wedding episode
and the tune that played when the slaughter
began.
But let me know what your favorite worst tywin
lannister moments are and what awful things
you think he’ll be doing to Tyrion in season
4.
Tonight the gore continues with a new Walking
Dead episode, be sure to subscribe to get
my video.
The governor is back.
As always be sure to let me know which Game
of Thrones character you want to talk about
next and any questions you have for season
4.
Right now click here to watch my season 4
preview for Tyrion and click here for that
new walking dead video.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tonight.
High Fives!